hey everyone I'm Alicia Malone from
Fandango movie clips and these are the
top ten moments from The Devil Wears
Prada just in time for its 10th
anniversary I feel old and for this
special celebration we have some actual
props from the film to share with you
they're delicate I have my gloves let's
get started number 10 our first glimpse
of the force of nature that is Miranda
Priestly it is sheer panic and mayhem as
the runway staff prepare for her arrival
and it all begins with Nigel's classic
line gird your loins shimmying down the
catwalk to number nine and his job
interview with Miranda painful kind of
like a fashionista version of a TSA body
scan it's orientation of number eight
andy's makeover reveal it's something we
often seen chick flicks but this one
signals her journey to the dark side she
does get a nod of approval from none
other than real-life supermodel Gisele
Bundchen and here I have the actual
runway magazine photo contact sheet
Nigel was hard at work on when Andy gets
the idea for her makeover number seven
evidence that Miranda has accepted Andy
in this classic moment where she
actually calls her by her real name fine
and ahndrea I would like you to deliver
the book to my hands right at number six
the book the holy grail of runway
magazines but it is also the physical
manifestation of Miranda's trust of Andy
always wanted to look inside whoo
hairbrush our number five a moment which
gives us a glimpse to the human side of
Miranda Priestly in this scene she
alerts Andy to a change in the seating
chart this very seating chart Stephen
isn't coming Oh
another divorce I'll be your plus-one
striding over to our number four and
these triumphant moment of completing
Miranda's impossible task obtaining the
unpublished manuscript of the new Harry
Potter novel coming in at number three
the moment we see Andy return to her
true self as she rejects the temptation
to follow in Miranda's high-heeled
footsteps number two comes at the end of
the movie it's a fleeting moment where
Miranda with a tip of her designer
sunglasses acknowledges her respect for
Andy who with a subtle head nod
acknowledges her gratitude to Miranda
it's all in the subtext and finally our
number one favorite moment from The
Devil Wears Prada
when Andy gets schooled by Miranda after
referring to fashion as stuff and it's
sort of comical how you think that
you've made a choice that exempts you
from the fashion industry when in fact
you're wearing a sweater that was
selected for you by the people in this
room from a pile of stuff well my fellow
fashionistas you could say that's all
for our top ten moments from The Devil
Wears Prada
I'm Alicia Malone for Fandango movie
clips bye